[Music]
hi chef how are you morning daddy puh
what's going on buddy
oh we're just killing in here we have a
question for you that we ask every year
yes would you rather win the NIT or be
one and done in the n-c-double-a
tournament NTA not even not even close
how about you were a newer New Orleans
last night you lost in the play-in game
or you in the NIT I I think you'd rather
be in the tournament I think you'd
rather see your name pop up on the
selection show and be a part of the Big
Dance although I I have to say I think
one of the I have great respect for
teams that do well in the NIT you know
the high major conference teams I think
the two years that's got through at
Baylor has not made the NCAA tournament
in this recent run he's gone to the
final game of the NIT so that that does
tell me something but I think he'd
always rather be in the NCAA tournament
you think yes
like if I have a young team I am I want
to be able to win the NIT if I have a
chance to win the NIT with the young
team I think we've seen in recent
history the teams that have done well in
the NIT won the NIT the following year I
think that they've had good seasons but
here's the other one
Indiana choosing not to host an NIT game
last time because they don't want Tom
Crean to get booed is that do you
understand it you know what I heard you
saying that as you're coming out I
actually had not heard that I didn't I
did not know that so I don't you know
I'm actually down here in Atlanta they
played right across the street from our
studio at Turner I hope we know find out
today what's what's happening I hope
that the ad there for a glass that
speaks out and either you know puts this
to rest one way or another because all
the twisting and the wind it just
doesn't do anybody any favors I like it
when they you know they've done it some
of these other schools at Ohio State and
you know and the opposite way at
Illinois just kind of settle things do
you think Tom Green's on his way on its
it's close I would say 51 51 49 yes I
think they want him to succeed there I
do so it's a question of is he trying to
get out of there or are they pushing
them out or as both sort of happening or
maybe they can live with it for another
year and he's gonna lose some guys this
year and there's there's not
you know a high-level recruiting class
coming in so it's hard to see how the
situation gets much better for him but
you know I think they want him to
succeed then announces they're hoping
that he does poorly and get him out of
there but hopefully we'll know soon when
the next 24-48 hours
Seth Davis from CBS sports the road to
the Final Four joining us Dan Patrick
show any outrage with the brackets
seating no I mean you know I always have
my cripples things that I might have
done differently but nothing you know
real outrageous I mean I still haven't
heard a good explanation for why North
Carolina would be seated ahead of Duke
on the overall seed line now you can
make a case for you know Arizona to be a
one seed ahead of both of them you could
definitely make a case for that but I
don't think there's any real case to be
made I mean Carolina had seven losses
Duke at eight Duke at much better wins
much better ones away from home and beat
Carolina twice so I thought that was
pretty prohibitive but overall you know
Wichita State seed a little bit low SMU
is a six I thought you know they got
kind of robbed but they're pretty
consistent with how they do things in
terms of you know valuing you know
really good RPI wins so you may like it
or not like it but it's not the
committee's role to change the
procedures it's the committee's role to
follow the procedures and I thought they
did a pretty good job right but when's
the last time you remember a 10th seed
as a six point favorite over a seven
seed well you know again it's it's uh
there are these predictive models out
there you know Ken pom is a great
efficiency side it's really a great
gambling side is what it is and you know
that's just not their mission you know
it's it's it's a they can only look at
if you look at what Utah state's wins
their best wins rover Illinois state you
know so what are you gonna do you can't
you can't say we're doing it one way and
then execute another way because you
know you you think how Vegas is gonna
act or how you know the saccharine
ratings are gonna be it's just it's just
a different set of criteria I think
people often conflate that okay sneaky
teams that could make it to the sweet 16
give me two of them
well you know I was really impressed
with Rhode Island I mean I know they
would have a potentially tough second
round game against Oregon of course I
got Creighton in the first round but
Rhode Island is a team that started off
the year ranked in the top 25 had some
injury issues lost a couple games to
very good teams early dropped out of the
top 25 percolated below the radar got
healthy late played better late won the
a-10 tournament I don't know if Middle
Tennessee sneaking up on buddy anymore I
think we think we've one of those things
we've said so much they're underrated
they are now overrated but you know I've
liked them all year
you know Minnesota lost their their lone
senior in the big 10 tournament and you
know Butler to me is one of those high
floor low ceiling type of teams so
Middle Tennessee basically brought back
its whole team last year and added their
leading scorer did not play on the team
that beat Michigan State let's remember
this just the ceiling is the roof the
ceiling is the roof the floor is the
heart and the basement yeah the floor is
the basement we I think we get confused
when people say oh this is wide open you
have a lot of teams who can win it and
my point is do we really have that many
teams who can win six games because
though and it feels like it's wide open
if this was one and done how many teams
could win it but how many teams do you
think can win it because you have to win
six but you know the the picture of the
dominant team you know a clear favorite
like I'll take that team you take the
field that happens like once every eight
years that's that is the aberration that
this is more normal where it might be
wide open but you don't have that many
teams in there I think you have probably
six to eight I think it's something like
over the last twenty years day and
two-thirds of the champions have been
one seeds and then there was one to seed
and a couple of threes and that's it I
mean the cream rises at the end of the
day so you know the idea that a team
below a two seed yes it's possible but
it's very very rare so I think you're
basically looking at eight teams that
are capable of winning this this whole
things it was one in done a very typical
year what about one and done that if you
were just saying how would this team
match up with
team how many of those how many of those
teams do you think could win a
championship if it was just single
elimination if it was but it single no
I'm saying it's just if we it's open to
win you have to win six in a row but if
you only had to win one game against
let's say North Carolina or one go
everybody
that's that's the beauty of the
tournament see any any team can beat you
know virtually any team can beat any
other team and I want it done situation
that that's absolute I mean especially
once you get past the second round with
the one and two season I've you've had
you know a small handful of 15s winning
first round games but beyond that those
guys once you get into the second round
all bets are off
in a one game scenario but you know
those teams that pull off an upset
they've got to do a game after game
after game and they have to you know
they have to handle all of the emotional
and psychological burdens if you will of
pulling off a great win it's very hard
for a team that's why I like when they
get to the sweet 16 they usually get
throttled because you know for North
Carolina they get to the sweet 16
everybody looks at each other and says
okay our seasons beginning now if
Florida Gulf Coast gets to the sweet 16
again they throw them a parade so now
they have to keep playing great teams
that's why I say in terms of winning one
game anything can happen but you know
six games in row it's really you know
four really really hard games in a row
very few teams are capable of doing that
I think single best NBA prospect in the
tournament is Markel fault
I'm sorry I read somewhere he's already
better than Steph Curry yeah but but
Jason Tatum at Duke is really rising
fast and then Josh Jackson will be the
other one at Kansas so it's definitely
gonna be a very freshman top-heavy draft
for sure but I love what Lonzo can do
and you know we'll see with that funky
release on his shot you know how that
works in the NBA but the NBA game was so
wide open the way he distributes it
passes it he's he's a sensational
players I'll go at Lazo
but to me marquel Falls should be the
number one pick in a draft most people
haven't seen a play that kid for today's
NBA the way he shoots it he's gonna be
sensational
I love Tatum I think Tatum's special I
think he's Carmelo without the baggage
not that Carmelo had a lot of bag is
coming out of college but yeah his game
room
a lot of Carmela he was helped out
though I think Seth because there was so
much attention on everybody else at Duke
with Coach K's health Canard you had
Grayson Allen and then all of a sudden
you watch whenever they needed a big
hoop and Tatum has come up big and he's
getting better as we move along you can
watch the progression there I think he's
gonna be a special player yeah I agree
and you know of course you know he had
his foot hurt early in the year and when
you're a freshman you know if you miss a
week that's like missing four especially
that time of year and then he came back
and they think I think they tried to
feature him a little too much and he had
too many habits from AAU and then you
lose a chef ski so you know for
everything that they've gone through no
then I keep referencing you know Malcolm
Gladwell's 10,000 hours like they
haven't had their 10,000 hours and I
didn't know if they had enough hours to
we don't work together and develop but I
think right now they're playing better
than any team in the country certainly
they can lose but they're my pick to win
the championship because of the
collection of talent and what they've
been through and of course they got a
fairly good coach there on the sidelines
to figure it out
we'll check in with you throughout the
tournament always appreciate your time
chef love you Dan that's Seth Davis love
you CBS Sports the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience